les terrasses retrouver synonyme de
liberté
c'est dire si elles sont chères au coeur
des français et ça depuis bien longtemps
à paris toujours beaucoup de monde aux
terrasses des cafés bien ce jeune homme
pourtant correctement mais tu n'as pas
de cravate
les terrasses rythme la journée donne le
pouls de la ville un ballet sans cesse
répétées 17h30
elles attendent le buveur de café le
travailleur en recherche d'un brin de
soleil avant de commencer sa journée un
garçon enlevé la veille un bar où l'on
viendra prendre son petit déjeuner la
terrasse c'est là où il faut être vu
aujourd'hui mais c'était déjà le cas
hier et le choix du bout de trottoir a
son importance pour sartre en 1946
c'était le floor d'un café de flore le
philosophe jean paul sartre
tient ses assises et d'un guéridon de
marbre fait une table de travail
le floor dans le quartier latin un
quartier où les terrasses étaient
envahis à midi par les étudiants dans
les années 60
ne croyez surtout pas que ces jeunes
gens viennent ici pour boire mais il
faut bien payer sa place comme dans tous
les pays à un café pour réviser pour
draguer ou simplement pour rêver car la
terrasse et le terrain de tous les
possibles
[Musique]
difficile à dire
sentir
alors toi seul mais entouré de personnes
et
c'est beaucoup plus vivant par exemple
taxez moi sur fait notre frère seul mais
entouré
voilà donc le secret des chaises en
rotin et des tables en marbre
mais si on y remplit son coeur qu'est ce
qu'on y voit souvent un café crème
pourquoi café crème bien c'est parce que
c'est moins cher
et oui car il ya un hic la terrasse pic
le portefeuille et c'était déjà le cas
en 1975 différents 35 si on fait la
conversion se la fermer pour une livre
et ça pour une bière ou un café en
angleterre ce serait terriblement cher
encore aujourd'hui bière citronnade jus
de pastèque tout est cher en terrasse
car en plus de la boisson on paye sa
place au théâtre on voit les gens sont
les jambes
les gens
c'est au néo mire la ville harris et
[Musique]